Hello, everybody! My name is Markiplier
and welcome back to Five Nights at Freddy's: Help Wanted
We are going on a bit of a treasure hunt
We're gonne be LOOKING
For ALLLLLLLLLLL the tapes that we possibly can get our hands on
Which means that we have to go through each and every one of these
and double check pretty much everything
YOU shut up
I don't care what you have to say
And I have to make sure that I've got allll the coins
In all these places--
Got that one (x2)
And then there was the one that was in the monitor here
I think I got everything here!
So considering that,
I think I'm good on the first..
Five Nights at Freddy's one
I think I've got everything 'cuz I've got 8 of the tapes
and I've got 13 of-- wow, you're closer than I thought you'd be
I've got 13 of 30 coins
which is good!
Which meeans that I'm not too far off from where I need to be
I just need to backtrack because I don't remember what I've got already
And uh- if you could stay far away from me that'd be great
So what I gotta do is-
I've got a little guiiide
that's telling me..
where..
everything is
Ohhhhh...
Interesting
So apparently,
Five Nights at Freddy's 2; there's a coin
that you can get if *phone rings* you put the mask on--
shut up
--over- oh! Whu-huh! Right there!
And then uhh...
There was a tape here, but I think I've got that already
I'm gonna let The Puppet get me!
(panicky) Where is it??
Oh shit!
That's not good..
OOOOO! I hate that!
Oh!
OH! *Balloon Boy starts laughing*
WAH!
I'LL TAKE IT!
I'LL TAKE IT! *BB's laugh starts spamming*
HEYYYYYY
*Marionette jumpscare* ha-AYYYE WHOA
FUCK
ME
GOOD
god..
Okay! Well, got that one!
*weird sheep-like laugh*
*weird sheep-like laugh pt. 2*
You're laughin'
I'm laughin'
We're all laughin'
*weird sheep-like laugh pt. 3*
So in Five Nights at Freddy's 3
*realization hits*
Ohhhhhhhh
3, 9, 5, 2, 4, 8
Uhh.. lemme do Night 2 just to...
(slight echo) DO IT
Five Nights at Freddy's 3..
there's apparent-
Oh-- no, no
This is wrong (x2) Wrong (x3)
*static*
So in Five Nights at Freddy's 3..
you remember how when I played the original,
there was a thing (keypad) in the wall
Oh, shit
There we go
Okay
3, 9, 5, 2, 4, 8
Hooooo!
And then!
There should be a tape...
AH-HA!!
HEYYYYYY!!
(echoing) T A P E!
Okay! There's supposedly one (tape) that appears in the vent
Now I don't know where or how or why..
but there...
apparently is
But it might be caused by "Ventilation Error"
I'm not 100% sure
*Balloon Boy laughs*
*Springtrap(?) jumpscare* WHOA! FUCK! There we go!
*alarm goes off* Okay! Ventilation!
Aha!
Oh, wait, no. I got that one already
Okay, nevermind!
We're good!
We're goOooOOOOooOd!
I'm gettin' wOoZyYy *alarm's still blaring*
*in silly voice* I'm gettin' WoOOzYy!
Ooh, boy, okay
So, what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna die horribly
Hi-loooo!
Hi
*in Goofy's voice* HeLLoO *waves*
Hi BiG bUnNy!
HoW yA dOiN??
YoU gOoO--*voicecrack*--OoD?
iM gOoOooOoOOd
i HoPe ThAt YoU rEmEmBeR Me FrOm LaSt TiMe!
wHeN i KiCkEd YoUr AsS
dO yOu 'MeMbEr? *BB laughs* Do YoU 'mEm-- WhOa!
*alarms blare*
wHeRe'D yA gOoOO?
i DoN't KnOw!
i DoN't FeEL sO gOoD!
LoOkS LiKe i MiGhT nEeD a LiTtLe..
HeLp
mAyBe SoMe Mo-- *normal voice* whoa!
*back to weird voice* MoUtH tO mOuTh MiGhT bE *inhales the word GoOooOd!*
*in normal voice* You suck!
If I win this, *Springtrap jumpscare*
OH, FUCK!
Hey, there ya are!
*bell rings* Oh, pwaff--
WAHHHHHH!
YA LO--
NO, NO NO!
Not so fast there, Buddy-boo!
I win
Wha--OOOOOHHHHHHH
Fyuck yoff with that shit!
Okay, whatever.. doesn't matter..
That's not why I'm here. I didn't even need to die
So, once I get it, I'm just gonna go
Enough jumpscares
Ooo, hey buddy
Alright..
We gotta do one!
Let's just listen to them as we go
I don't like you getting close like that, but here we go
Okay tape-- wait did we listen to tape 9?
I think we did, didn't we?
Yeah. We did
Uh-huh...
Ahhh...
Uh-HUH!
Okay!
Uh-huh!
You think you could've just made one tape being like,
"Hey look out for that thing! That bunny? Okay, look out for that!"
You know, you didn't need to record every single one of these.
These said something about file size
This?
IS A WASTE OF FILE SIZE
Hi-- w o a h
Gettin' a little twitchy there, aren't ya?
Hey buddy, you getting a little twitchy, yeah?
*High pitched* Heyyyy you getting a little twitchy?
OOOOOOOoooo
Okay, alright
So in... Dark Rooms: Nightmare BB; there's a coin and a tape. I don't know if I got either of them
There ya are
If I look up,
Oh! Hi! There it is. Oh shit. There-- there it is!
Then on the floor to the right apparently?
Nightmare BB: Hello?
Hello? Hi. Hang on one second I gotta--
Do a thing here
I don't know- why, why does this open? *Confused Mark sounds*
*sped-up Balloon Boy laugh*
Woah!
Fuck off, you
Okay I must've got-- what the fuc-- I don't get why-- why do you open??
I don't-- Nightmare BB: Hello?
Alright you know what? Fuck you BB! Come get me! Come on! You think I'm scared of you? Huh?
You think I'm scared of y-- Yeah come on!
DO IT! Come on do it! Hey, come on!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, what you got? Nothin'??
Oh, that's what I thought!
I thought you got a whole lot a nothing! I thought I got a whole lot a something and you got a nothing!
Come o- OOOOOOOHHHHH!!!!
*Lip bubbles*
Next is Parts & Service and there's-- I think there's something in all of these that I've missed
'Cause apparently,
and I didn't know this, maybe just because I didn't think of trying it--
You son of a bitch
*weird sheep-like laugh pt. 2354262*
*weird sheep-like laugh pt. 456324* Thank you!
*starts strumming Bonnie's guitar*
I think that's all I need in here because I got the other ones
Okay
Hey, buddy!
DOINK!
*angry bonbon*
Your doing allot of this I need you to do some of this okay?
I'm becoming numb to you
You ain't gonna sass me because I am way to sass-able
So I'm just gonna go ahead and go into Chica's 'cause I *know* that there's something there that I can do
Boink!
So apparently, if you do this...
Here ya go
*ChOMp*
*too many weird sheep-like laughs to count* Thank you for that!
*More ChoMPS*
Oh I'm eating it alright
There ya go!
Yay, all the pizza! I'm a glutton, what can I say?
*Strange Mark sounds* Thats the first time I've won that
Uh Chica Chu-- Chica Chug! Love it!
*ChOMP*
So apparently, theres a bunch of stuff here, that I didn't get.
Okay its funny actually, its funny. You're gonna laugh.
You're gonna laugh!
Okay I got that one
But uh, behind Freddy's...
Le-- Oh!
Well there's that!
But behind Freddy's left ear...
Aahhh! Hahaha- hey hey hey!
Alright.
DOinKuS
AAAAHHH!! TO SOON TO SOON!?
HUH!? TOO SOON!?
Thats so funny, behind his left ear
Thats adorable, okay
But we got another tape
So your e-OH you are real PROXIMAL to me
How about in the nightmare world are ya any closer?
No. 'Cause ya suck!
Alright
Tape tiiime!
Alrighty, thennnnnnn
Uh-huh...
Great! Yeah that's good
Yeah, that's good to know
Uh-huh
THAT WAS A MISTAKE!
THAT WAS VERY CLEARLY A MISTAKE!
YA DUMB!
WHY WO-- IF YOU KNEW THAT IT WAS ATTACHED TO THE LOGS YOU SHOU--
THESE LOGS AREN'T IM-POR-TANT!
THESE LOGS ARE NONSENSE!!
THEY'RE JUST YOU COMPLAINING ABOUT YOUR JOB!
THATS ALL I'M HEARING!
MY GOOOOD!
MY GOOOOOOOOO-
Apparently,
Oh wow there it is
I don't know how I didn't notice that when I was going through this before
But there's another tape
BOiNk!
Hi! you are VERY close.!
DoINKUS
Uh-- uh-- DOinKuS
Hey, listen, buddy!
LISTEN
You,
are BIG and I am sssss-- mmmm average
I'm average
*mockingly* Oh, I can't delete them
Uh-huh!
So you can't destroy them?
Right, yeah
UH-HUH!
OOOOOHHH!! YOUR IDEAS HAVE BEEN GOING SO GOOD SO FAR!
GREAT IDEAS!
BUB!
WHATEVER YOUR NAME IS!
Uh-huh!
No!
You can ask! Oh, you can ask, alright!
I just ain't gonna follow! Ya know what I'm saying about that?
So with Foxy, as I discovered before,
has a quirky little fun trick that you're able to do in there is,
you're able to do this
Oh! There she is!
Yeeeeee!
Do you want this?
Do you-- WOaH
Get me!
Hit me!
Ohhh you're harmless!
Uh-oh!
Wow, what a dent of that tookas!
Yeah, whatever..
Ahhh, DOInK!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, whatever, NERD!!
I ain't even afraid anymore!
I am big brave
I am big brave and you are... *confused Mark noises* big also but I am big brave
So that was another coin, that was not another, tape
So vent repair
In here, there's apparently both a coin and a tape
I may have gotten the tape in this one, I'm not 100% sure, I just gotta check.
A-Oh! I did not apparently.
*Mark laughs*
*in Goofy's voice again* WeLcOmE tO vEnT rEpAiR!
BoINK
NERD
STUPI-Oh wait I hate this one
Oh, I forgot I hate this one
OOH I HATE THIS ONE
OH I forgot I forgo-- EOUUUHOUGH